in the u.s new travel restrictions take
effect today in response to the omicron
variant errol barnett is at the dulles
international airport outside washington
errol good morning
hey there good morning president biden
announced this decision on friday and
today foreign travelers will feel the
impact this ban applying to south africa
and seven other southern african nations
including zimbabwe u.s citizens and
permanent residents are excluded from
this restriction so long as they show a
negative covered test meanwhile up in
canada officials there have confirmed
the country's first two omicron cases in
ottawa on sunday both of those patients
traveled from nigeria this is the most
populous country on the african
continent in central west africa but it
is not a part of this u.s restriction
list delta and united are two u.s
airlines with direct flights to south
africa they're both telling cbs news
they have no plans to cancel or delay
any of their flights at this time you
know various health officials see this
ban as a way of delaying the spread and
buying time for people to get vaccinated
and to get boosted but there's no
uniformity right now in how the world is
responding to this consider that today
morocco is joining japan and israel gail
in banning all foreign travelers from
entering those countries
all right we heard that thank you very
much errol